[Music]
I've got to mention one thing this is
absolutely a true story yesterday after
the show as I was taking my 45 layers of
makeup offshore my assistant came in and
she said there was someone in the crowd
in the show whose friends was someone
who went to high school with me back in
the day and they were going through some
stuff recently piles of old photos and
they found a photo of me when I believe
I'm like a sophomore in high school
mm-hmm and I was a drummer in a band and
yeah and I don't know whether to be
embarrassed or proud of this photo but
in the interest of full disclosure this
is me I'm a Brookline high school I'm
gonna guess somewhere around what spec I
don't look at don't look at me yeah 2004
or 2005 you know I think it's a Bush's
second term and anyway this is me
they found this photo and that is
actually me drumming getting their code
[Music]
I'm wearing aviator shades and I don't
know worm check out I had a drum set
called a courtly which is the I think
the worst drum set ever made
no drummers ever heard of a courtly it's
all I could afford
so yeah that's me rocking out playing
the latest hit by Katrina and the way
it's a one for one second the people at
courtly were like he mentioned us
oh just trust me trust me they are not
making drums anymore recording they're
now making prosthetic feet you know
drums but steel drums to put waste in
yeah